[Music]
[Music]
the focus in the United States on
research ethics began with the news of
the research done by Nazi physicians on
concentration camp prisoners during
World War two there was a war crimes
trial held in the city of Nuremberg
which produced the Nuremberg code the
first international code of ethics for
research on human subjects in the United
States interest in the topic was
reawakened in the mid to late 1960s when
we got reports of unethical research
being done including the Tuskegee
syphilis studies some of the key cases
that attracted the attention of the
United States Congress to the issue they
studied quite a number of other
suspected cases and in response to this
created a National Commission called the
National Commission for the protection
of human research subjects one of its
most famous products was the so-called
Belmont report I personally as a
consultant to the Commission was the
co-author of the Belmont report with Tom
Beecham another consultant from
Georgetown University we had no idea
when we wrote this thing of what
influence it would have we thought it
might guide the development of
regulations in the United States but
instead it became the standard
declaration of ethical principles for
research not only in the in the United
States but
in most of the rest of the world but
although we must be evolving our ethical
standards in order to be responsive not
only to the technological but other
standards evolution of other
considerations relevant to the time but
we have to be on guard against what I
call the appearance of infinite
malleability that is will change the
ethical codes any way that's necessary
in order to allow the science to go
forward that's something that I believe
we cannot do we cannot simply be
responsive to the technological demands
of scientific development but we must
give them due consideration and come out
with standards that are responsive to
all the relevant considerations of the
time and place
[Music]